okay
coming up
place your bets
who from this list
who from this list right here and there
are others that i'm sure you can't see
who is gonna win place your bets
who is it gonna be
okay
let's get down to business
let's go mouse you could do it
um
less than five
warzone rated 82 players 1771 average
rating let's go
bang
let's go
let's roll
h-pawn save the day
let's go
get on this diagonal
okay well i have to do something a bit
different
and let's do this
i'm thinking about f6 i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with f6
well i'm gonna go with this though first
okay let's try this going a little crazy
i know
okay they're ready to
blow this right open here
get out of there knight i cannot deal
with you
definitely cannot deal with you
i don't want him to get to a4 either
get away
get out
all right my light square bishop wants
to be here i think
actually let's get more development in h
pawns
let's go i have that knight secure
support that pawn takes i'm on the
bishop
you see it
takes i'm on the bishop i'm on the
bishop i'm on the bishop
uh oh
they gonna move
get that knight out of there
um
let's open this up
i'm covering these squares here they
have very little time i can't wait to
see what in the world
let's just do this
and then this anything
time burners
time burners where are you at down who
has
ah man
somebody has 59 points
look at the corruption
it's corrupt
this guy loves me apparently
they love me enough to burn the clock
oh man is this all done for me i feel
special
i feel very special now i'm gonna
pre-move this and see i'm gonna track
down this clown
i'm gonna track down them
59 what's he doing
he's got 59 points
we're only three minutes in
still no movement here
from somebody who loves me they're not
moving
how does this guy have 59 points what's
the what's the trick here what am i
missing out on
um
also the chat i'm not able to see any of
the the chat filtering in so that kind
of stinks
um
59 points this beast has how much time
okay i gotta close out of this my game
is starting soon
games leaders where am i at
i don't know where i'm at
oh
another sneak artist
another sneak artist
another sneak artist here
oh
sneaky
sneaky
ah sneak artist
i got a piece can i convert it
oh
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneaky
watch out
come on let's trade
we're gonna go for a draw
hit that rook
let's go here you can't avoid queen
exchanges
come on you should be winning
you should definitely be winning
are you winning
oh
hang on hang on now
watch out
watch out
kill a rook kill either rook kill a
knight
oh man
man
shouldn't they be winning are they
winning
oh man
hang on they're being sneaky pins oh is
that uncomfortable
oh man
hang on get out there rook get out of
there
pigs i'm hitting him with a pig one pig
two pigs
two pigs are better than one
checks
stalemates
checks checks
more checks where's the mate
mate
boom
i'm gonna take that one
it may seem like i'm trash talking but i
only do that knowing against those
who should be beating me because they're
better players they're being sneaky
they're being sneaky you just have to
know i'm right with that
uh oh uh oh the queen is gone
the queen is gone is this another sneak
artist
is it
i don't know i can't say that for
certain with this one
but
they're everywhere
they're everywhere
we're the mates
oh this one here
sneaky again the points are at least
doubled for this one
ah
here we go
we got mates the queen is dead
going right after the king next there's
checkarooskies on d7 there's bishop f4s
there's queen c7s there's
knight g5s or b5 d5 you name it
what's going on elsewhere
75 points
60
75 and 60 are top
crazy
98
somebody has 98
10 and 11 games have been played
ah man
there
they have no time queen sack back to
tournament 18 i'm in 20th somebody has
10 and 11 games in
okay this is this is a legitimate guy i
know this guy he's a good guy
this guy is a good guy here
he's one of the good guys
stay good
stay good here here we go
i'm gonna do this i want that light
squared bishop and then i could play to
e4
look at the e4 let's do it right now
also knight right there would be good
castle
b5
let's take that
oh i'm dropping that with check
actually they would end up dropping a
minor piece
if they did that let's hang under my
rook
or am i a c4 pawn i mean b3 might be
pretty good
i'll go like this so i can get my knight
to uh e7
e7 and then right here looking for forks
if that pawn pushes queen here hitting
the rook and hitting a lot of stuff over
here
maybe get in uh
what do i want to get in
let's get over here before my queen is
trapped i almost missed that i could
grab here too
forks
take here and then i take the knight
oh big problems
take here no matter what
actually hang on let's do this
do this no matter what
check and then where's the mate
i don't want to take the queen i want to
okay they resigned back to tournament
there was just like a glimmer of hope in
my voice right there did you hear it i
said back to the tournament like i was
gonna be uh doing some damage like i was
really gonna be coming back
back to tournament i only need 90 points
back to tournament i'm only 90 points
away
okay
let's roll here
queenside castle
get out of there night
let's go
checks checks
castle
what's the plan
i gotta do this
i have to watch for queen takes here but
i have this covered by my rook
right here night block oh that's that
could be taken
oh this is very scary
oh
man
right here is it working out
i think
clock situation is actually on my side
here
okay
oh
man i'm on the rook now
push this guy up right here i should get
to that square
no more bad pre-moves
it's just more more the same
more bad pre-moves wherever you look
uh-oh
that pawn is fast
mate in okay they resigned
actually say it again back to tournament
i could do it 40 points i have
killer check
oh
okay this is one of the sneak artists i
can feel it already
one of the sneak artists negative 37
i could just feel it within the first
couple of moves
it's my sixth sense kicking in
the sixth sense
my bishop gonna be trapped
maybe
oh okay
hang on
you better win this
you better win this
gonna take you're gonna grab that pawn
let's do this
and then can i get that pawn my knight
incoming
takes pawn
27 seconds
take that let's guard here
what's my knight doing
can i get this
get rid of that night
let's go here
and then uh
let's go here if we trade bishops i want
to be able to get that pawn
and i think i want to back up like this
i get these pawns going i'm not even
doing anything here
not even doing anything
dropping that pawn 24 ticks
i don't have anything
get that pawn
ah
oh hit the resign button
you should win that one
you should win that one
ah man
ah
what can you do
what can you do it was close
i guess
man
ah
queenside castle don't you dare give up
don't you dare give up
now's not
that was not the time to be giving up
let's go
mate
mate h7
oh back to tournament i'm only down how
much 150 160 points
jonathan
okay
let's get this pawnee
let's break down that center
and let's get development that's why i
want that instead of the pun let's go
okay i'm getting up upon here
up upon i should have grabbed the queen
grab that queen
i'm gonna grab it now
structural damage
can't do that
king is gonna be good on c6 let me get
this a file
king up to c6
nice and cozy right here
get out of there night
get out of there night
oh
very scary
okay let's push here
better not be mate
my knight needs to help out
let's go here knight
forks
pins pin and then win
king activity don't take pinned pieces
whatever you do
there's still a lot of time left in this
tournament
they're down back to tournament they
resigned 68 i mean 17th
214 is top guy
the top dog
uh
bishop c4
i'd have three and uh
okay oh i shouldn't have allowed that i
okay let's do this they're getting me
the d5 square
pin this knight and then play knight to
d5 that's the plan
okay they should probably play h6 and g5
i'm gonna sack on g5
i'm gonna do this
and uh follow up with knight to d6 this
is actually working
this is actually working this was tried
earlier in that two minute game deadly
fork
resign time i'm on the queen
i'm on the rook
i could give a check on f6 oh the
kitchen sink
kitchen sink variation where's the mate
one of these two
check
check and then mate just move back to
tournament what do we have
86
234 196.
this is an honest guy right here rael
here's a good guy right here he's one of
the good guys
rael that was a mouse slip i could i
feel your pain with those metal slips
f3 and then f4 i know
i know how you feel on that one
okay let's let's go here i'm heading for
the e3 square
let's get there
let's go
no let's do that knight here next if you
take here four karooskies if not i have
connected past pawn forks
forks the queen or the rook
queen of the rook
oh i should have saved my knight
i should have played the b3
open this up i need to square i need to
break at this structure in some way
pawn push i push here i want to get rid
of the knight and play queen to d5
oh night right here is going to be
pretty good
pressure i should take that knight
let's take him now and then take here
and then just take that knight next
and let's just take the knight next
and then get here even though if that
that uh f pawn falls i got the bishop
now
resign time they're down back to
tournament they resigned 106. i'm in
17th
24 games up top
let's do this here uh oh uh oh this guy
has zero points
i'm nervous
i'm nervous when they have a few points
okay wait
um
no okay this guy i think is pretty
legitimate here this is another good guy
another good guy here
bishop takes f4 and then i'm looking at
f7 very closely
get some more development in
fully developed knight takes pawn is
available because i'm moving too fast
okay they missed that i want to take on
h6 maybe
maybe
let's see what the bishop wants to do
what is he gonna do
i'm gonna do this
i have queen to g6 as a checking move
because this pawn is pinned
like right now
checks and then
this is check and where's the mate gonna
be
right here
capture the night and then play here
if the knight moves it's mate
and if it doesn't move i take it and
then it's me pretty sure
are they gonna move
11 minutes left in this tournament this
is unavoidable
unless the bishop plays to f 5 but they
didn't back determine
126.
yo
killer check oh
here we go sneak attack
sneak attack
how much a 30 30-second lead
30-second lead here
what do we have going on
oh
take that night you know you want to
take that knight
take the knight
he's free and you know he's free
uh oh
oh i'm on the bishop
where's the mate
oh is it mate i get the queen with check
killer check
killer check
uh oh
uh oh
time burner killer check going down you
had a 30 second lead and you're a good
player
you should be beating me every time
every time
uh oh
you're not beating me
keep in mind if you're new
there's some sneaky stuff going on here
he is
um
a really good player
who is being sneaky ah another sneak
move another sneaky move
now it'll melt the clock
milking the clock
now it'll be a non-mover right to the
very end i got the w
a 30 second lead
a 30 second lead was there
nine minutes and change
oh
here we go
bishop c4
f4 knight f3
wow a 30-second lead and you couldn't
get me right there and you are a master
level player come on you should be
beating me every time
every time
take the e6 pawn
e6 pawn take them okay knight d5 f6
knight here i want to grab on f7 and
then discover tricks right here there's
a fork as well
uh oh
big trouble
right around every corner i believe
b6 f7 pawn push
let's take here
tricky discoveries are in the air
this seems like a good one
and then
we got mate coming up
let's get the
queen
no no no let's do this no let's take the
rook
just move quick
take the knight and then play here so i
get the queen
here we go now i can push the pawn
because the pawn is pinned to the rook
and then maybe give some sneaky checks
okay we have a pin here push that rook
around maybe
okay i get this rook or yeah i get the
rook here
so this is this is a good guy right here
chess newbie
this is a legitimate player right here
he's legit
seven
okay back to tournament
uh 166 324 is in top right here william
b another good guy
another good guy here
william b
who is
um
okay let's go
william b is a good guy and a good
player
okay let's take here
queen b6 hit this pawn hit b2
um i don't want to take b2 though i'm
afraid
i don't want to take that pawn
um
slow and steady
get your development in
open up no no no no over here
over here oh grab this knight maybe
attack that knight
queen to a5 guard here maybe recapture
my queen
oh i missed that
i was on that night
could do trades
i really don't want to take because i
want to have keep control over this
square i want my king on
oh let's take now
change of plan
get that bishop no forks the whole
family's hit
the whole family was hit on that one
ah a lot of pieces died right there a
lot of pieces just died in those uh
that sequence of moves right there
pieces falling okay they resigned back
to tournament 186 i'm in 15th can i get
top 10 that will be an accomplishment
deadly fork
oh i don't know what to think of deadly
fork yet
we're gonna see
uh oh
deadly fork
sneak attack
i can feel it the sixth sense
i have a sixth sense
let's take this
scar that is the queen gonna come out
there that's okay
my king is gonna be nice and safe right
here
or is he
or is he
uh oh
or is he uh oh
uh oh no i'm scared
you know you want to take that and then
give a check you know you want to give
check
run over here king no right here is
better
get rid of that knight no over here you
know it's going to be safe over here
avoid the queen exchange
that queen is almost dead this knight
needs to get out of here
let's come over here then
not going to get rid of him come on over
here
all right that knight needs to go he
definitely needs to go right here
right here we're gonna have trades 18
seconds
over here
over here
can i give a check right here i'm
hitting that three times
it's to be defended
don't block with the pun
right here
watch out
sneaky stuff sneaky stuff
what do we have here
oh
oh oh oh oh sneaky stuff
sneaky stuff i'm on the queen
where's she gonna go uh oh
oh man
where's the mates
where are those mates
can i get mates
ah
i only have two seconds
no time
ah
what can you do
so close
sort of
ah man
you can do it you can get first
don't have any quit in you
353
queen c7 knight f6 b5 bishop b7
hang on you castle i'll play bishop d6
only after the castle otherwise you have
to be prepared for sacrifices on b5 be
aware of that
right here
if i do this before the king is castle
there's problems so now i'm looking at
the dark square diagonal
i'm okay with the doubled pawns here my
king can have a nice home right there
let's give a check knight h5 and then to
g3
maybe get this pun
or not
i'm on the rook
let's do this oh i just there's a
wonderful square right here for that
bishop now
a great square
oh
that knight was there they missed that
back my bishop all the way up and then
do what oh let's get out of that before
it is too late
before it's too late i need to get rid
of that bishop he's too good
right here
right here i want this pun
i get that
with check they're offering a draw i
don't want to draw
they're in check okay castle pawn push
here defend my bishop
and then get my rooks right here i have
a time edge
right here defense stuff
double rooks can grab that pawn maybe at
some point right now is a good point
okay grab here with check rook takes
pawn
easy one to miss
pile up on g2
pawn push here
smash through at this point now g2 has
hit a bunch
checks on c1 as well back to tournament
i got 200 i'll take 200
21st
nokia
nokia 81
ah
bishop c4
f4
knight f3
castles
coming up
nokia seems legit
a good guy another good
guy right here rookie one hang on
weaknesses on f7
right over here pawn push
takes takes takes oh i'm on the night
pac-man mode
pac-man mode okay
right here i'm on that bishop
take here i pawn push
pawn push
and uh just wanna do this
i'm gonna take there okay let's back up
probably pawn push was gonna happen
there anyhow
forks if the queen takes i have this
same thing
mate and one two
and then three
sneaky back determined 224
20th one minute remaining it's going to
be called at any moment
oh
known fried
negative 122 i think they're gonna start
to play
can i get this
with the h-pawn of all things
uh-oh
uh-oh can i get this one again
uh-oh
oh
hang on
hang on
they must be scared
must be scared
uh oh
oh
am i gonna get it again
not again i can't win another game
oh it's going to be called before
anything
it'll definitely be called
um there's only 10 seconds left
i'm on the rook doesn't really matter
though
can i always let the clock burn
i'm going to claim a win though
oh thanks for playing a 21st
more corruption
120 games
120 games
that's crazy
good games oh
more nonsense 400
362 354 313
and then 288 this is insane that's crazy
okay